vision is a classic marvel character now
known to millions as part of the mcu
from his humble roots in the comics to
his unique story on screen this is
everything you don't know about the
mysterious android
vision may be the most popular character
with that name in the marvel universe
but he wasn't the first to claim the
moniker
decades before the vision you know first
appeared a totally different character
named vision appeared in 1940's marvel
mystery comics number 13.
also operating under the name arcus this
vision is an alien who has teleportation
and ice based superpowers
he occasionally fights alongside
superheroes like the human torch and
namor as part of the invaders an early
marvel superhero team
in the 1960s a number of these classic
golden age characters including captain
america and neymar came back into the
spotlight vision however
was not lucky enough to receive this
treatment though comics writer roy ryder
initially wanted to revive arcus for the
1960s
company mandates forced him to create a
new character for the name vision to be
applied to instead
thus the very first vision in marvel
comics history quickly faded into
obscurity however that doesn't mean this
early vision has been totally forgotten
since the 1970s arcus has managed to
make a handful of appearances in the
comics
including the 2013 x-men legacy story
line
most recently he managed to become a
playable character in the mobile video
game marvel contest of champions
some superheroes like to dress
exclusively in bleak colors
not so for vision this particular
avenger is readily identifiable by his
head to toe bold colors
a yellow cape and gloves complement
vision's green body and red face
he's easy to spot in any crowd however
his distinct look wasn't popular with
one very important person at marvel
creator roy thomas explained to the
hollywood reporter stanley hated the
color of the vision
why'd you make him red red's not a good
color i didn't want to make him green
like the hulk or blue like the
atlanteans i suppose i could have made
him white but the paper we printed on
was so poor that you would have been
able to see the other side so we didn't
make things white that we didn't have to
though stan lee wasn't initially
satisfied with vision's colors it's
those same hues that have made him one
of the most visually distinctive marvel
superheroes around
sometimes iconic characters come about
due to spur the moment creative
inspiration
others like vision come out of something
as simple as a mandate from a boss
according to roy thomas vision was
created as a solution to stan lee's
mandate for new avengers members
thomas explained to yahoo stan suddenly
said it was time to make up a new
character to bring in a new avenger
i didn't like to create new characters
for marvel because i wouldn't own
them i wanted to bring back the old
vision but stan wanted an android
he didn't say why he just said he wanted
the new character to be an android
thus the vision the world knows and
loves was born all thanks to stan lee's
insistence on an android adventure
it may not be the glossiest origin story
for an iconic superhero but lee's
mandate did have its advantages
chiefly it immediately helped make
vision stand out on any avengers roster
and still does in fact
the distinguished superhero team is at
all kinds of unusual members but an
android like vision still manages to
catch your attention all these years
later
in the 50 plus years he's existed vision
has often drawn comparisons to star trek
spock
it isn't hard to see why on the surface
there is the fact that they're both
sci-fi characters introduced in the late
1960s
on a deeper more specific level they're
both no-nonsense figures who are usually
the only non-humanoid members of their
group
what does thomas say about these
comparisons he told yahoo people have
told me they see a resemblance to mr
spock
if there is i didn't do it consciously i
was vaguely aware of the show
we would play poker while our wives and
kids sat in the next room watching star
trek so i would hear the tv playing
rather than using spock as a model
thomas actually drew inspiration from a
robot named adam link and otto bender's
short story irobot
in this tale which also inspired isaac
asimov's book of the same name
link is falsely accused of murdering his
creator in the ensuing chaos link
becomes all too aware of the adverse
effects his very existence has on human
beings who are immediately suspicious of
a robot
adam link's tragically self-conscious
qualities are immediately apparent in
vision in addition to the character's
unintentional overlap with mr spock
in the marvel cinematic universe vision
is played by actor paul bettany
prior to his multi-film turn his vision
betany appeared in a wide variety of
movies
among those acting credits was an
earlier role in the mcu as tony stark's
ai helper jarvis
jarvis you there that's your service a
reimagining to the comics edwin jarvis
who is a human butler jarvis was not a
role that bettany initially put much
stock in
at the time of iron man's release betany
said that while he was recording his
voice work for jarvis he didn't actually
know that it was for a superhero movie
while betany started out as an outsider
oblivious to the larger machinations of
the marvel cinematic universe he didn't
remain that way for long
after playing jarvis across four
different mcu installments it was
announced in february 2014 that betany
would be taken on a physical role in the
mcu's vision
when joss whedon was putting together
his ideas for avengers age of ultron
he intended to use the mammoth box
office success of the original avengers
to realize some of his grander ambitions
specifically he wanted to use ultron as
the primary villain and introduced
vision as played by paul bettany
like many of whedon's plans for age of
ultron this was a notion he had carried
with him long before the cameras even
started rolling on the first avengers
movie he told collider
before i took the first avengers i said
well i don't know if i'm right for this
or if i want it or you want me
but in the second one the villain has to
be ultron and he has to create the
vision
and then that has to be paul bettany
whedon went on to note that his
fascination with the character derives
from vision's unusual power set
as well as the fact that vision was a
focal point to the comics he grew up
reading
as for his long-standing dream of having
bethany inhabit the role the director
joked that betany's sharp cheekbones
make him a natural fit for the part
though he's existed for over half a
century in the marvel comics canon
vision has usually acted as a supporting
player first introduced in the comics as
a creation of ultron who was convinced
to fight back against his creator vision
subsequently became a fixture of the
avengers comic books
over the years vision is factored
prominently into the avengers adventures
the wedding between himself and scarlet
witch even acts as the centerpiece of
giant size avengers number four
still being a standout member of an
ensemble is not the same thing as
headlining your own comic series a feat
that most other marvel superheroes have
been able to do regularly
while vision has been a supporting
player for most of his fictional life he
still played a major role in numerous
story lines that have shaped the marvel
universe moreover the characters managed
to secure a handful of solo adventures
over the years
the first of these was a four-issue
vision series published in 1994 by bob
harris and manny clark
more recent his 2015's 12 issue vision
series by tom king and gabriel hernandez
walter
even if vision isn't a go-to figure for
headlining marvel comic books
these acclaimed stories starring the
mysterious character show the value
vision has
as a leading man if you're going to be a
superhero in the marvel cinematic
universe you're gonna have to put on an
elaborate costume sometimes this costume
is the motion capture suit mark ruffalo
has to wear to portray the hulk
other times it's a patriotic getup chris
evans had to pull on to captain america
in the case of paul bettany properly
portraying vision means having to
undergo extensive application of makeup
and prosthetics
transforming betany into the boldly
colored vision is not an easy task
a two-hour process is required to make
the man into the machine perfecting
vision's look proved to be a
time-consuming task even in the concept
stage
well before paul bettany took his seat
in the makeup chair the makeup artists
for avengers age of ultron were so
determined to get the character's unique
look right that they put extraordinary
effort into mocking up some prototypes
for the final product
makeup artist nick williams told makeup
artist magazine in 2015
the makeup went through a lot of stages
in order to make the lines absolutely
perfect as though he was born from a
computer we actually sculpted the makeup
in 3d
over a cyber scan of paul's head and
printed out in clear plastic
while vision's look wasn't easy to put
together all this exacting effort
certainly paid off
vision came to the silver screen looking
like he'd walk straight out of a comic
book
vision isn't the first character to
carry that moniker in the comics so it
should be no surprise that he's also not
the last character to bear that name
either whereas the vision created in
1967
is a massive departure from the one
created in the 1940s though the newest
superheroes to carry on the vision name
have been directly inspired by the
crimson colored android
in 2005 a new version of vision debuted
in young avengers number 5. while he
looks like a dead ringer for the
original vision this new hero is younger
and goes by the name jonas
speaking of newer and younger versions
of vision the mainstream vision's most
notable superhero successor emerged in
the form of his own daughter vibvision
first appearing in vision number one the
character starts out as one part of
vision's fragmented attempt to create a
traditional american nuclear family for
himself
in the years since that run viv is
blossomed into a standalone superhero in
her own right
in a 2018 interview betany revealed that
the chance to portray vision in the
marvel cinematic universe came just as
it looked like his acting opportunities
were about to dry up
i had just had a meeting with a producer
who will remain
nameless who told me that my career was
over
for a short time after that meeting the
actor was gripped with despair before
getting a phone call from age of ultron
director joss whedon whedon proceeded to
ask if betany wanted to play vision in
the then
upcoming avengers sequel now one phone
call turned things around for bethany
completely as betany reflected to
insider i sort of looked up to heaven
and thought karma's very quick these
days
it happened just like that i sat down
and my phone rang very funny but you
know if i had a dollar for every time
somebody told me my career was over
my career could be over since then
betany has portrayed vision in a number
of mcu titles and the franchise's first
disney plus series won division
beyond the mcu betany has also landed
roles in films like solo a star wars
story and uncle frank
so whoever it was who said bethany's
career was over just moments before he
landed one of the biggest roles of his
career
probably needs to have their own vision
checked check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite comics characters are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one